Let's hope the drinking bird look a bit better still by having its body made out
of glass. I'll do the geometry improvements, you do the glass material. I've now
split the body into two pieces, an exterior shell and an interior blue fluid. On
the left, the blue fluid here is without the shell. And on the right is how
things look with the shell. Clearly the shell needs to be made well clear in
order to see the fluid inside. Your job is to make this material transparent.
The fluid's material is called body material in the code. The glass body uses a
new material called glass material. The current glass material's shininess is
fine as it's set, but otherwise, needs fixing. I want you to set the glass
bodies materials so that it's 30% opaque, and of course, transparent. Regular
material color, fully black, in other words, 000. And the specular color, fully
white, 111. When you have the glass materials set correctly, your solution
should look something like this.